it's like why do I have obliques I'm not
even doing anything yeah I ride the
airtime bike and I take my [__]
seriously maybe I maybe I stop eating
[__] you look like those guys in
that American Gladiator you know what I
look like you know what I look like I
look like that 56 year old who's trying
to stop time and the internet's full of
this
both guys who are even more muscular
because they're all on trt but think
about if I get on trt bro whoa I'm gonna
be a
tight loser who gets even grayer and
thinner skin it's not a good look this
is already embarrassing that looks great
bro very fish like huh this is it this
is look this is this is what happens
when you don't lose your insecurity and
you're 56 and you're still working out
and doing what you can but nothing
really changes
sorry about all those shreds I hope you
guys don't have a snake phobia because
that looks like snakes
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I want to start this uh episode off with
the fact that uh Brennan and I have been
friends now for going on 13 years and
only 13. I don't know what it is but you
know that you're you know that your good
friends when you can look at your friend
and lie to him and then no I lied over
texts can you guys come back at three
o'clock and you go no
I have to be in Hollywood at 2 30 and I
went by Hollywood I was like interesting
okay because I I guess I I we won't do
the podcast of three because I had I
want to do something in Texas and I got
a whole account's feet to the fire a
little bit because he's treating us like
a side piece yep and I like the crowded
chick a little bit right you keep
canceling shows we got you keep coming
in late so I was wait you know what not
today I'm alive
now no what's funny is when I got that
text I kind of knew I was like ah my
dear friend's lying to me and then we
get here and it's 12 48 so I know that
he doesn't have to be in Hollywood I
love we had the Sears talking he'd walk
with me go where did we just had a
really serious talk a great talk about
um about comedy and careers by the
elbows and I go hey can I talk to you
you don't have you don't have to be in
Hollywood at 2 30 do you and he goes
okay here's the thing I lied
and because you bothered me sometimes
and I had to lie
hold your feet to the fire and he said
and here's the real reason I needed to
be out here
I didn't know when I was going to get my
truck and my truck is priority over
everything I have a new truck it's a ram
it's a TX whatever the [__] it is a
T-Rex TRX and uh I didn't know if it's
gonna pick it up like at 12 or I was
going to pick it up at 2 30. by the way
you know I had to clear my slate and you
had to take the fall yeah and I went you
know I get it at least I was honest now
you were honest now now that that truck
is a big bad boy I don't all I see is a
what looks like a fancy pickup truck
yeah it's got but it's got a it's got a
little hump on the on the hood looks
like it needs air oh it needs all the it
needs all the air you're talking about
that hood scoop that got a 62 liter or
something it's a 6.2 liter V8 which
they're not making them anymore that's
why I want to jump on it now good gas
mileage obviously about nine miles per
gallon nine miles and now you drive some
get five got it okay it's the opposite
of Tesla the opposite on the opposite
direction but we got some we got some we
got some uh heat okay that's the
sandblast Edition I picked up so we got
705 horse bar now you know Daddy can't
leave that thing alone I've already
started talking to other guys with TRX
about modding this bad boy I said red
and I go I said I said well hold on can
you just can you get a Denali and before
I got Denali out he goes no no no that's
not possible
I know but pretty extreme you have to
have an extreme now that would be the
family car or that's the family car
that's a family because that will fit
the two tiger in Boston that'll fit
Jordan very safe super safe but big big
not taking prisoners fit the the new
little one that comes in December in the
back you want that bad boy just for just
to teach people a lesson just to be like
um is that is that what it is or I I
don't know man I got problems I got
problems you got some problems between
that a raptor I had the fans vote online
most people have voted for the for the
TRX because the Raptor's a V6 twin turbo
Raptor great truck but can't do the V6
okay
the V6 V6 smaller engine it's a you you
can't do the V6 not a truck no no you
need a V8 yeah and you want a V8 because
of the sound or because it's going away
you know and then also I want this
particular model uh sandblast Edition
2022 because 23s and 24s that are coming
out and they're again they're not making
them anymore but the 23s 24s come with
all digital screen the 2022s are the
last ones that come with actual gauges
ah cage so I don't like all digital you
need the gate I need a stone cold gauge
yeah you know you don't want you don't
want to see the gas you don't want an
iPad on Wheels you want you want gauges
oh I'm old school you're old school how
many here's my question how many uh how
many
leftists own that truck would you say
how many or how many how many
liberal academics dude I'm not even
lying right now yeah I think Nancy
Pelosi drives that
the cheese but she's also so uh killer
like she's also
when Nancy Pelosi when she was when she
was stuck in the bowels of the capital
during the the uh January 6th thing I
got I I had a newfound respect for her
because she goes uh I'm gonna hit him
when I see him I'm gonna hit him I'm
gonna hit him I'm gonna punch him right
in the face
yep I'm gonna go to jail and I'm gonna
be happy and I went that's the Italian
dinner yeah that's that I went oh that's
why you're about us so it hurts her
daughter said my mom can cut your head
off and you don't even realize what
happened tits I mean she's an attractive
older lady I'm sad dude when she was
younger like you got one in the red
dress yeah she I find her to be very
attractive and if she was here I'm not
in I'm not in in sync with her politics
for the most part a little bit you are
well she's probably the kind of person
that's super smart and bring that up
no that's real that is real that is not
fake news but she's real yeah
yeah
right there that's all fake too but but
she's she's a woman who was when she was
younger
she was she's probably an old school
Democrat which I don't have any problem
with
uh listen she has those sweater puppies
man I don't give a [__] about her
politics she's smarter she's smart as
[__] that's that she's hot there that's
my type and she still had the Heavies
she's hot right there that's a good
looking woman intelligent as hell I know
I'm gonna get a lot of [__] from
everybody who's you know smart uh right
wing but but she's attractive and smart
and we'd have arguments we'd have
political arguments and then we'd have
sex no don't say that we'd have sex but
that that'd be and then she then she'd
give you insider trading dude you make
money gets that from her husband well
both yeah it'd be a good time she's uh
she looks like such a sweetie but her
daughter said she'll she'll cut your
head off before you realize that your
head's been cut off she's just a master
yeah back to her Heavies though right
forget politics so it's boring dude if
she had those Heavies out though she had
those Heavies out whatever you want man
I want hold on B let's take a break all
right fine but I want nuts do you want I
want watery nuts buttery round nuts do
you have a million dollars though well
because I tried buying some macadamia
nuts and they were like million bucks
you need you need to figure out a way to
work with South African farmers and get
a company that's cornered the market so
that they can bring the price down does
that even exist well let me ask you this
you ever heard of macadamia nuts you
know they're buttery and creamy and
they're super exciting like 100 keto
friendly yeah well then what if I said
um I'll put I'll put white chocolate
around them or or milk we make a bar for
me
how about you want some you want some
macadamia nut oil it gives your steak a
buttery flavor oh my god look I can keep
going does this exist
House of macadamias all right that's
what exists now I know it's crazy to say
to you guys buy nuts over the internet I
know that's the craziest thing to say
but there might be no healthier nut on
the planet they've got a fat profile
that not only satiates your appetite so
if you're looking to lose weight it's
probably the best thing you can do in
terms of like not eating a lot but
feeling like you're full but dude if you
say that house of macadamias never gives
a discount and they're going to give oh
really watch this yeah dude what I'm
about to freak out I'm gonna give you
enough you guys here's a here's an offer
dude AK is the tfak is the my voice gets
deeper dude all right you can use the
discount yes I'll give you a free box of
45 Macadamia snack bars when I say 45
it's it's made of 45 pure macadamia nuts
not a bunch of filler okay one of each
flavor how about that so visit House of
macadamus because it's a house full of
macadamia nuts I mean that's what I
think
I'm gonna order nuts over the Internet
yeah you are and get the best macadamia
nuts you've ever see what happens
houseomeacademias.com tfak 20 off and a
box of 45 get your Omega sevens get your
omega.com
I was with these professional um hockey
players they're savages savages and this
two girls were there very pretty and we
were all hanging out and they didn't
know these two girls but the two girls
were kind of looking at these guys sure
they had been on my show they thought I
was cute but they were like looking at
the hockey players and the one guy and
this one guy and we're talking and stuff
and this one girl had these impossible
breasts she was so hot she was Canadian
but just she wasn't a stripper she was
just hot yeah probably and he's going
like this this guy keeps going like this
he goes he was just this dude who was
just [__] by missing a tooth yeah and
he goes get those juggies
at the table he goes let's see those
juggies and he would like
yeah she was attracted to him so she
would go she'd go like this she'd go
okay whatever okay all right I'm gonna
do that right here yeah and then he gets
up to go to the bathroom and he takes
his pants down so you see
he walks to the bathroom with his pants
10 years ago before the metoo movement
oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
12 years yeah to do that these days
you're a wild boy oh yeah yeah now he
but but when you're a monster hockey
player and a starter in the NHL you're
allowed to do you love juggies girls
love him and I see his ass and it was
the nicest ass it was all muscle but one
of those yeah I got it apple bottoms and
I went well she's done now because she
was like she looked at him she goes
that's a really nice ass so she says
that's why he took his pants down then
he comes back and we're all talking and
everyone's like he was drunk and he
drank more and he'd go get those juggies
out let's see those juggies though
was everyone like hey can you just I was
can you please can you take it down
we're talking about Nancy Pelosi yeah I
said to him like oh you must relax sir
you must just rock hard get this Juggy
oh God because then that became my thing
and I was making the oven
juggies is hilarious and then they
hooked up that night of course so he got
the juggies out he got mission
accomplished did you see that dude I
don't listen I don't know if it's fake
news I don't know if I trust it I
retweeted it on my uh platform I think
it's a Tucker Carlson interview but he
interviews the former method who's
missing a tooth who says he hooked up
with Barack Obama of course yeah said
twice yeah
that's true do we believe him or I do I
I don't think all Barry no the only
reason I believe him is because hold on
real quick Brian believes Big Gulp Berry
hooked up with this toothless crackhead
well more so than Epstein didn't kill
himself I want that on the record yeah
well oh there he is oh boy
yeah but see here's my thing about this
guy he's not attractive so but do you
talk about this back in the day now
embarrassing wasn't that attractive
either boys
19.99. let me look for him he says it's
19.99 okay now I'm really not buying it
well that's 24 years ago yeah that's a
long time that's when I was born yeah 24
years ago that's a long time ago yeah he
about to look different
oh there he is there yeah but he had
Coke ah so it could have been like the
you know and he just any game do you
talk about a suck and snort can I answer
yourself dude hold on hold on be a
second you know what I'm Santa sucks
it's a good time if you're a gay man a
second a little bit of a good time
I'm gonna name my new truck the second
snort when you're when you're there hold
on let me see former president Michelle
Obama I've seen in the US Open last week
that's just like random pictures in this
article he looks stressed
look at the end of the day let's just be
honest I I'm sorry anybody cares I know
why this is a story Mr Mr Obama probably
is somewhat attracted to men or has gone
through his phases and and there's no
gay phase bro well I agree you don't
suck and snort and just stop well you
but then again there are probably
straight guys that when crack hits their
system they're just like I'll take
anything that's a good point he did say
big old Barry smoked it he was sniffing
it so if you're gonna smoke smoke and
suck yeah hey hey you're already if
you're gonna smoke crack you're already
in a whorehouse in what in your mind I
mean you've already gone over to the
dark side so if some guy is like it was
like this I told you the story when when
we were um me and Jimmy Burke were on a
cruise one time we were young men I was
a cutie pie 30 something no there was a
guy there I was in my 30s I was probably
33 who knows and there was a guy who was
a dancer he was a dancer and he had a
perm hell yeah and he had these eyes and
he had a little mouth he was probably
and he was so [__] cute yeah and he
was but he was a twink
and and he said to Jimmy he said I would
love to suck your [__] and Jimmy was
like Jimmy goes your dick jumps up a
little bit Jimmy goes he grabbed his
face and he goes here's the thing you
gotta know Jimmy he goes here's the
thing I would love that and you are
[__] adorable and don't think I
didn't see that little ass that little
apple bottom in those shorts and I've
been thinking about it too but I have a
problem and do you know what that
problem is and he goes
and he goes I love
but if that changes
I'm coming and I'm coming hard yeah you
okay yep and then the guy hung out with
us and it was something you guys half of
the sucking snore it was like Jim can
and that was the it was the cruise that
Jimmy Burke wore a [__] blue napkin
he tied it like a little bow he's giving
off the vibe because he could he has a
long neck he had to cover it for his son
and he wouldn't take it off the whole
time yeah so he looked like he plays for
the other two yeah with a and then we'd
be there sitting like this drinking a
beer and I would you know looking girls
and there were these the national the
British national rugby team all built
like you and bigger all these rough guys
and uh I'm looking at them oh Jesus you
guys are [__] like cheese and he
would go come here honey all right and
he put his arm around me and pretend he
was my boyfriend I like get your [__]
arm off my hips what is uh is anybody oh
yeah but what I was saying because the
Tucker Crossing interview is he getting
picked up like on Fox I don't see it on
mainstream because obviously Tucker's a
bit of the enemy because of that so I
don't I doubt in his interviews are
getting picked up by Fox CNN's
definitely not running sucking snort
stories these are the top ones pink News
Daily Mail look the guy might be a con
artist too he might be looking for
attention he might be looking to write a
book you know but I don't think it's
far-fetched
my thing if you're Tucker Carlson with
this biggest platform in the world right
now if you're Tucker Carlson
shouldn't you do a little background
check on this guy for the Second Story
well the rumors have been around for a
long time do you know that oh yeah so
the rumors about Obama being gay have
been around since I think even before
his girlfriend in college deleted she
took out the talk about homosexuality
for him so she so is well known in the
circus he just wasn't mainstream yet
because it would have affect it well in
during the campaign when he was running
and they said we're going to uh now
whether this is true or not but they
said that the campaign said if you if
you run this [__] we're not going to
Grant you access you can do this you
want to start off if you want to start
the relationship off like this you guys
can go ahead but you know there are
better there are better stories and I
think people in The Newsroom of these
different places were like look this guy
is the first black president he's
totally beloved we all suck and snort
you know what I mean it's like are we
really gonna do this with are we really
going to be sensationalists and talk
about his sex life when we have other
problems in this country but you're
talking about a different time
immediately now like now I get it like
say Trump had some that background or
DeSantis or insert you know dossier the
[__] Steele that Christopher Steele
does yeah that that was financed by the
clintons by Hillary Clinton's campaign
said that he pissed on hookers in Russia
and it's like no he didn't that was all
a lie it was all [__] even if he did
I don't I don't get why anybody I guess
you don't want your president doing that
stuff yeah I'm not in it he was a kid
yeah like do those last year all right
people are into weird [__] but I'm not
into that but what I'm saying is that it
was all a lie it was all [__] and I
you know the question is how how deep do
you want to go into this stuff you think
John F Kennedy wasn't banging everything
all the all the hookers and all the
actresses and all that he's my guy yeah
there was some [__] going on that people
didn't know about but also like why come
out with it now like he's retired he has
no influence really
like why come out now
just to make the Democrats look bad I I
think
um okay I'm just doing it themselves
maybe to make Biden's son look better I
think it's just a Stratford
I think people want a story it's been
out there forever like to suck and snort
yeah but nowadays you get paid for
clicks sounds like a great story sounds
like something we should talk about I
wonder if Tucker pays them
yeah I think he got paid for that
interview that guy needs it open Money
but I think he wants to write a book or
something he wants more snort but he'll
suck yeah it doesn't work out does it
crack it doesn't work out uh his tooth
gave up yeah
but also if you're Barack you're
probably like God dip that guy from the
early 90s that guy out of all the guys I
[__]
like the guy with the one tooth is
coming out yeah yeah like a little suck
and snort dude but that dick is the
worst looking one out of all of them I
know
it's also like the women that come out
on Trump he hooked up with him 40 years
ago they were different women not just
these warlocks just well he just lost uh
the second defamation trial hey Trump
don't call her a whack job you if
somebody accuses you and you you even
say that they're lying you can get sued
people so if somebody tells you is a
black job someone tells the story about
you and you say she's a liar if you say
that you can get sued yeah you because
you think you would notice
we called her a whack job you're not
allowed to say that yeah but boy is he
right she's a weirdo she's she's
yeah none of them are attractive like
come out yeah
Brock's sucking snort side piece just
brutal dude well he I'll tell you what
just a collection Carol's a lot hotter
than Larry Sinclair I mean as far as I'm
concerned ah it's about roll the dice
yeah yeah I got a second snore whatever
whoever shows up for a good time right
yeah well
yeah dude I was watching uh this
documentary on Netflix last night
uh it's like the silent lady killer but
it says she was the first serial killer
in Mexico
she's a woman she's a woman she killed
like 40 but she only killed old grandmas
look at her the lady yeah Lady of
Silence she only killed old grandmas
they couldn't catch her forever look at
her forever yeah from like yeah 98 2006
she she got I think they convicted on 17
murders but they there's like 47 at
least psycho and she would do it the
same way she would find out which old
people were living by themselves or home
alone go in there pretend she worked for
the state or for the Department they'd
let her in and she'd take either
pantyhose or uh electrical cords and
strangle all of them and not put
fingerprints on them she's just
strangling all of them so they knew she
was strong
was she a Lucha Libre
fake one she bought all the gear herself
and hung out with the wrestlers but not
never actually wrestled that's where the
look at her though she's strong
they thought a man was doing so they
arrested a transgender man he's like I
didn't do this [__] because they thought
you'd have to be a man to be that strong
evil psycho got off on killing they go
under they go under uh her childhood
that's where it stems from her mom sold
her
to uh old man for a six-pack of bear
when she was a kid and the old man
abused her and he was old so she
combined old people and then women her
mom and that's how she took them all
right yep she's a handsome face very
hands man what a what a uh that she's
got a lot of dude when they catch her
they just going through and she goes
yeah I did it you got me what do you
want me to do like whatever you do
what a weird world what a
call yeah she's a big guy in the Mexican
Government the police are so they're so
stupid dude it took forever she's just
killing these ladies left and right well
you just don't think of an a lady doing
it right well they they had to call and
help from America and from France
because Francis had some horrible serial
killers so they were like all right
here's here's their patterns that's what
you gotta look for like this
they gave her 174 years you know it's
like what what in the [__] is 65. think
about the tragedy of your mother selling
you as a little we have children you
know who else did that I can't handle
who else Charles Manson's mom sold him
for a a one cup of beer you know some
people should have children some people
shouldn't have children we all know that
I haven't some don't want about that
where it's like I think when some people
get pregnant even God is like oh no yes
true yeah and and you know
like I I don't know how you could do
that to a child when you have a child
walk off it's about walking off after
you swim for six I can't Bears I can't
bear that thought that poor kid I cannot
dude I can't bear the thought that a
child is out there being is suffering
yeah I really can't horrible
man not bad but just the point is don't
let a woman with short hair like that
square jaw come into your home yeah and
definitely don't feature on the news
she's a brutal brutal dude
oh yeah
yeah are you excited for the fights this
weekend sure we're headed to Austin on
Saturday I keep forgetting we got us we
got our shows I'm gonna tell you on this
we got shows on Friday at Covina come on
Daddy come on come on now come on tell
that baby I think there are what 20 more
tickets left or are they if now that was
earlier yeah
yeah we're called the dude the sucking
snort tour yeah you're the sock on the
snow oh no no I'm not sucking dude if
you let me make that promo poster yeah
I'll be the suck no you're gonna be the
suck and I'm the old I'm the old guy
smoking no old snort and young suck old
snort and snort old snorting suck the
old school old snort young suck yeah old
snort young sock sucking snort's the
name of that that's the name of this
episode
yeah cause I mean there's nothing wrong
with snorting old snort young suck
there's anything wrong with sucking no
everyone's let's go through this card
because we don't say snort cocaine suck
[__]
[Music]
are you in the Splash Zone
yeah and then we just have a the the the
image just the elephant with a big trunk
just snorting cocaine
I don't know if anybody's gonna make
that shirt when I was in Colombia when I
was in Colombia I said to him I said how
much uh because the guy was there and he
was like he was he was Mr everything you
know you always get a guy who's Mr
everything there and he goes
if you guys want this I can get you you
know if you you want some drugs I go how
much is cocaine here he says we have we
have flavored cooking I can get you the
best for ten dollars yeah just so
prevalent and I was like wow if there's
a place to do cocaine it's in Columbia
yeah you know there's not fentanyl the
Chinese haven't touched it yet yeah I
don't want my heart to stop though in
Colombia we don't need to snort all the
ghosts you can't be doing cocaine I
agree it's not good am I don't flying
right now I'll say you've got Adderall
same [__] oh really then sign me up yeah
now you don't that's a hard sell don't
tell me that you know I love that stuff
I know I know I know why would you guys
you like Adderall this is that
supercharger yeah well it was the best
sale of all time sorry about it yeah I'm
gonna become sucking store real yeah but
the problem is if you don't know what's
in glow like they put Columbia I do
shouldn't do it in Columbia I do never
know out here I would never the amount
of processing that goes into cocaine
like gasoline yeah [__] just do it yeah
you're in Colombia wow can't do it yeah
oh then then you're sucking because I'll
be snorting no I'll smoke it no no no no
no no
yeah does it smoking I feel is better
than sniffing I don't know yeah because
do you have to worry about the Fentanyl
and stuff
it's freebasing drugs enter your body
then so so you so so so Richard Pryor
was free basing cocaine he was smoking
it and that's when he got caught on fire
yeah
maximal concentration if you if you
smoke yeah it just hits your system a
lot quicker and it tends to make your
dong apparently rock hard no so no I
heard it by the way it worked okay
smoking versus snorting oh yeah snorting
I heard you smoke I heard you got limp
it depends it depends smoking is uh
snowman snorting can also cause that
issue they were cutting cocaine I think
with uh like Viagra and stuff yeah I
don't know if that's yeah
yeah LAX it is yeah but either way
you're in Colombia when When in Rome am
I right are you one in Rome do a little
of that all right what do you got Tim
for the you brought up the fight card
yeah yeah because we're heading to us on
Saturday do the fight command we're
going to be talking to the whole thing
because we're not going to be watching
too much of this
unless you have something you're really
excited about I mean I'm excited for
tattoo I am too Justin taffa us and
Lane's a fun one uh my guy I would like
to get Jimmy Malarkey's fun to watch and
then uh would it would it be weird if I
went into volkov's Camp yes and I and I
walked in there and I said excuse me
guys how come he's not working with the
best boxing coach and just learning how
to jab people in their face well
Alexander volkov yeah what like I missed
a good camp but why wouldn't you the
striking's pretty good but but you're as
a fighter why wouldn't you jab somebody
to death with your and I felt the same
way about stroof Stroup never used his
chat he's slow but use yourself come so
far away in the heavyweight division
guys are coming over the top with the
right hand is that what it is he's seven
foot so he's going so when you're so
your job
all day okay yeah so you but what if you
dip your head to the left you might get
neat or kicked get kicked in the face
dude yeah dip your head to the left yeah
so that's what happens then so you you
if you're in a heavyweight so tied two
of us would time it and just come over
yeah and they're gonna eat the jab and
come over the top all day Oh They'll eat
the jacket eat it just to lie in the
right hand oh [__] the jab's not gonna
end the fight okay but I mean obviously
the narrative on this entire card and
hopefully it picks up with the press
conferences but Sean Strickland Izzy
so we'll see now this is Strickland's
verbatim word for word at the he did an
interview I forget which outlet and they
go off the Izzy's kind of downfall if
you want to pick something is this
grappling his wrestling and they go Sean
are you planning to go on there and use
your wrestling he goes you'd think but
then I'd get in there and I just I go
into [__] mode
all right man he's just gonna be that
guy man well he's like I'm gonna stand
there and bang it'll be a 30-second
fight if he does that I don't think he's
that dumb we'll see he's gonna try to
wrestle him ah we'll get a combination
of that I think it I think he's gonna
realize it's tougher to take Izzy down
than you think everyone thinks because
John did it's easy no he's a Savage man
he knows that's his downfall so he's
been working on that you know I just I
just don't see a path to victory for
Sean Strickland it's a tough one and I
like Sean I just don't see his what's
your take on tied to obasa
he's been top seven for what [__]
damn near 10 years
yeah that's a tough fight for for Ty for
sure really yeah
but who doesn't like well he can take so
much he can take a lot of punishment
unless he's fighting uh what's his name
you know you can see it it's like you
got
uh you got surrogate Sergey and Cyril
gone yeah
[Music]
it's just sergey's time Spivak too got
him out of there well with guy he can't
you can't even though you have a face
all the Heavy Hitters I mean he beat
Derek Lewis that was like a
flip the coin there but he's lost uh
these high level guys like dos Santos
high level Spirits high level Derrick
Lewis uh Cerro gone Sergey the real high
level guys his brawling style he gets in
trouble it's volkov's a technician be a
tough fight for him tough fight but he
always has that one chance
how tall is six seven six seven yeah
five six seven Big Boy yep six seven
yeah
yeah I trained with him at uh black
house did you really yep did you Spar or
you used this bar yeah really yeah he's
a beast Jesus Christ
with giant guys like that that must be
so much fun on a Tuesday [__] off
[Music]
it's Tuesday at black house and you walk
in and you've got to go you've got to go
[__] with volkov you gotta go oh that's
my sparring partner like his big legs
shins Something's Gonna Get hurt you
know who's the exact same size but more
skilled with was Gus uh Alexander Gus oh
dear I've never seen anything like
man I mean I've trained with John John
was so dominant it's hard to tell how
good he was but obviously the best to
ever do it but Alexander Gustin in his
prime best I've ever seen in the gym
I was at that fight live when he
basically tied with John they look like
they they were both so [__] up after
that fight that's that's when I beat
Montreal same card that's right that's
why I was there choked him out that's
why he went that's right and then and
then you sucked and snorted after
remember
you suck me well I snorted yep I kept
saying Yeah Yeah Big Gulp you took you
took giant mitrion I said pretend your
baby elephant what yeah yeah got him in
that dark stroke yep first round make
sure you don't give a thumbs up yeah
they went to sleep
yeah that was tough now did you know yet
yeah oh yeah that's my [__] but um
remember that and then there was uh
yeah but the cards at the bottom line
back to the car it's not a great card no
Tyson just in top Austin lanes are fun
with that [__] in pretty quick that's a
rematch too because uh Justin
Lane used to play uh in the NFL
he hasn't been fined that long but and
he came off data white Contender series
stud
y but again there's not enough hours in
the day to get to the top 6 16. they
play at Murray State Murray State yeah
he's had a lot he had what a four-year
career
yeah that's what it looks like ended on
my baby 66 265. that means he's cutting
a 65. Jesus Christ giant guy this is not
enough hours today to make up for
technique
nope
how long has he been training not not
too long
I'll see super gifted athletically yeah
tatted up yeah it's a big fella looking
for snort and sucked this Saturday in
Australia dude
look at that
ready
supposed to be fun though I'm glad we're
doing companions Samoa is he from
uh yeah all right what do you got Jen
oh actually let's start with the
you're drinking already huh me and
Georgie because we thought we're gonna
go get dinner we're doing tomorrow all
right no not dinner I've never said
dinner it's always been or lunch yeah
whatever yeah it'll be in like a
celebration yeah
um
let's see here Georgie I need your help
on this I'll tell you what speaking of
snorting sucking I'll tell you something
I I gobbled down you gobble down dude
can I ask you a question you know how my
truck as a supercharger yeah my brain
right now in line what's going on with
your brain oh dude I'm a little foggy I
feel like a V6 you want to get some you
want to get Flow State you want to get
some mental Clarity yeah I could use it
you want to bring stress levels down
when I want my create creativity to
spark up and I and it's my brain's
saying quit saying snorting suck yeah I
take a little this little magic mine for
mental Clarity because it is Magic yep
and it's for your mind you'll get into a
flow State I'll tell you that much right
makes you feel present uh here's what I
noticed I my my tongue in my brain link
up they link up and I'm glad you
reminded me of this because I forgot we
had you know I like that too
I feel less stressful on this stuff man
a little distressor I like the taste I
start I stopped thinking about snorting
and sake when I take it yeah and I like
the taste every time every time people
take it they go like this they go they
taste it
um
and they look at it and they go
yeah think of licking a lawnmower with
stevia yeah I think if you put Stevia
all over here I love that grass seed
like I love wheat shark yeah I love all
that we for me it tastes like um it's
got a
Tangy kind of
yeah yeah there's like some lemon in it
maybe
yes something like that it feels like
that's what I feel you like a lemonade
bottled in the OG Venice
what's this
well I was on How I Met Your Mother oh
yeah so let's see if you're doing here
and I was on Family Matters
what are we doing here this is great
I'll tell you in a second I love these
games chin
do you though I really do I beat the
[__] out of your last one did you have
fun yeah
all right let me uh set this up real
quick
okay so these are sitcom theme songs and
it was tough because okay so by the way
on the right side of it you see there's
a check box on the left yeah that just
that's just to see which ones you got
right but the right side just write down
the number what you thought okay so here
we go theme songs theme songs sitcom
theme songs and it's tough because I'm
younger than Bry I'm older than friend
so I had to like pick you know sitcoms
between those sides so I don't know
let's see here we go right so here's the
first one I think this is the easiest
I'll play it for just a little bit
foreign
if you don't get this you're a [__]
oh you gotta think about it yeah you
stupid and I come and play for a little
bit because I don't want to get flagged
yo you stupid
shut up you're stupid
yeah all right next one number two
imma knock on our door come and knock on
my door that's why you're waiting for
you we'll be waiting for you
good
you got them yeah all right number three
whatever happened to predictability the
Milkman the paper boy
that's it
hmm
it's not that easy I remember going
through this pretty easy I mean it's
pretty easy but you think pretty easy I
read all these books number four
[Music]
I bet you got that one you old [__] yo
oh I got this one shut up shut up number
five
foreign
[Music]
number six
lost what could be the future
oh man I think Brandon's gonna sweep
this maybe I'm I need to hear the theme
you see that's the thing I can't the
course okay I'll play one more time just
for this one
[Music]
lost
future could you pay the cost you want
will there ever be it's the second time
the reason why I didn't put the entire
song is because if the chorus has the
name of the song in it
good enough
all right that's enough okay last one
hold on hold on
um
we're on six right okay
last one we did seven last time so we'll
do seven again for this one all right so
seven hold on hold on all right no we're
on six no no we're gonna be on seven
right now I'm gonna play E7
oh okay
it's super serious go ahead you ready
this is number seven last one
[Applause]
mm-hmm
we get it yep do we got it I think I'm
gonna win this
yeah right I I too I'm confused on two
of them here's the uh winning answers so
Georgie wants to announce the win all
right tune number one is the office okay
yes
check
on time if I got I'm either perfect or I
missed two
number two Three's Company yes
yes
yes tune number three Full House [__]
too easy
[__]
to number four taxi yes I feel like you
both got that one two number five Family
Matters [__] that's where it gets
confused that's where I [__] up yeah
see
tune number six step by step I told you
I missed two yes
and two number seven How I Met Your yes
there's no way Brian wanted this one is
it how many did you get right I got one
two three four five five I got five oh
so it's a tie looks like this because I
got confused on Family Matters I told
you it seems like it's easy to move the
course I can't believe it I guessed I
guessed right though I didn't know about
it I was on How I Met Your Mother yeah I
don't even know I I never yeah how you
met your mother I don't believe me I
didn't watch the
episodes
that was good though you guys did try
five five
so I'm one one and you won the last one
I nominated last one was ten eight round
wait we did like we did three we did
those invoices Asian faces yeah does he
have downs and then um you know so Brian
won the first one right I did that on
mine Brenda won the second one right bro
you want the first one I don't yeah it
was it won the first I won the second so
you guys are tired damn we're up oh this
is good yeah it sucks and who snorted
it's good you should do like animal
sounds like the Roars of different
that's a good idea oh that's kind of
stupid though right
of the little thing that spins and it
lands on or just sounds that animals
make you know no that's a that's a good
idea I'll figure it out dude do your
animal farts oh that's good that's again
how the hell yeah this is cool look it
up Tim there's no way dude my [__]
bear Dragon hissed at me last night I'm
gonna slap the [__] out of stupid lizard
you should
what's going on your legs you're not
hitting that dragon
dude he's mean to me
I put a heating pad and he's not nice
what do you got Jim all right doing that
I'm obsessed with that aerodyne bite
because I hate it so much
pain so Conor McGregor was awarded
awarded his black belt from John
Kavanaugh recently and the biggest thing
about this story is like how many people
are talking smack for some reason well
it took place at the Alta training
program well even uh Ulta here no this
is their oh gotcha well even Kabir was
like who the [__] gave you your black
belt yeah different levels the black
belt you know yeah well but they did
press this cool thing where Connor like
in 2012 was like I want my black belt uh
two million dollars in the bank yeah
yeah two championship belts like he's
achieved everything
and his coach Kavanaugh respond back
goes wf2 million on you right now in
cash
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool yeah good for him
though yeah that's a real black boat
yeah
uh so this yeah it's a real black belt
yeah it's black well some guys get their
black belts like there's there's a big
difference between a competition a guy
who competes in United nine day right
Connor's not that good no no so depend
what you say real is you know yeah well
it's an MMA block about those that's
real right he's he's what would you say
is the difference like some stuff in
competition Jiu Jitsu obviously doesn't
work in MMA no not even that like it's
just you know those guys that are
dedicated to Jujitsu right you know it's
just different different and it depends
on your teacher it depends on your
teacher I know some guys because they're
friends with a teacher after 12 years
you know they got their black belt
eventually you know not really as good
as a you know a blue belt from Enzo's or
Molly since no yeah they get destroyed
I'm glad you said that because you're a
blue belt I'm a cancer blue belt okay we
understand each other now yeah do we
understand each other it doesn't matter
and and I will say this with all respect
and you know we've we've Tangled with us
I've never opened up on you I know that
I appreciate it right I've never truly
opened up on you
've been in my heart I believe but say
after the shows uh in Covina on Friday
if I look around the room I go
I get the snort down I need somebody to
suck and you're just in that room you
have no choice right so what's
interesting about that is that um
because I could literally Force I could
open up your stupid old cryptic mouth
yeah and just use it as a whole
one-handed so it's interesting you say
that because I've I've and I really mean
this we've never gone
real takedowns in the sense that I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna shoot on you sure
we've never gone on like literally just
tangling again and I believe in my heart
that I could get behind you
sure because you have Tendencies and you
make mistakes and let's if you don't if
I win that battle you gotta suck and and
provide the snort
hey if I get behind you you're not
getting me
in front of you right
I'm gonna crab up on your ass and you're
gonna feel what feels like a [__]
school bus parked in your ass
[Laughter]
biting my earlobe why are you biting on
top of my cartilage [__] my
tortellini ear yeah and why do I why is
there a school bus parked in my [__]
and I go to a happy place and then you
go to your happy place wherever that is
because uh we doing a little Sinclair
you need to save this for your boy Obama
man
what's this here oh okay so this is I
think an open workouts for UFC 293 and
this is Israel arasania saying something
I'll just play for you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like hands up if you were here
does he beat him for the belt
[Music]
he said hands up if you're there when I
uh when I won the bell in 2019 and Rob
Whitaker's in the crowd races here
all right here's something that went
viral it's a Maryland cop and he's
hooking up with this chick and by the
way the he's like doing it so like
lackada days ago there's like a family
in front of him he doesn't care so I'll
play this video yeah we got a video of
him playing hanky-panky yep yeah
so there's some family filming and with
kids around him too
and what was she it was a kid who was
just like by the way he's cheating on
his wife here so that's another part of
this viral story Apple Bottom on him too
you can see they're walking towards the
back because she's tiny police car he's
big she's tiny she might be a cute he's
rock hard right now by the way
yeah
there's kids running around which is
weird
the most careless yeah but where's this
at this isn't America it's in Maryland
that's Maryland holy [__] Maryland's
looking rougher is that yeah so that's
his girl wait that's the girl hold on
the video that's his wife is hot too
hold on that's the wife yeah this guy's
doing it and she was like talking you
know she's obviously the video is so
viral that she has to see it all the
time which sucks for her
yeah you gotta respect everybody in this
like just leave it alone you know keep
scrolling down yeah so this time for her
stuff apparently this is also in
Maryland another cop and another chick
well these barely cops are wow but we
don't know what's happening here it just
looks
why why are these Mexicans ratting out
all these cops yeah hey guys it's just
Mexican I don't know what's going on
exactly well you know it's just a video
of her just going in this cop car
who knows what happened there dude these
cops are I'm sure in the back seat of
the car
yeah maybe it was like uh you know it's
like it's like a field trip yeah it's
like it's tough she's got he's got kids
maybe it's a field trip to Cops this
house is on fire his house is on fire
right now maybe it's a field trip to
come down USA yeah that's that's a ride
along yeah you know
my buddy's brother was a cop uh I won't
say where but he got fired because he
kept arresting prostitutes he's like I
gotta take in unless
well there was a Cox bill there was a
cop I met through an actor here in Los
Angeles when I was 28 years old and uh
he he was telling a story that I was
just like he's no longer a cop anymore
because he was you know but he was like
you know the thing is she was drunk
and I was like what do you do for a
living honey and she was like
I'm a paralegal and goes well you can
kiss that job goodbye because I'm going
to impound your car and then she's like
well is there anything I can do anything
yeah
I thought to myself I drink and drive I
don't want to be a hypocrite I'll let
you off you take care of the kids
somebody told me the story so did you do
it third party from another famous
comedian so did she do this and and yes
they got in the back seat and they got
they got it on and then on the side of
the highway in Jersey they got fired
there was a lot of stuff he was doing if
you're gonna do that you're probably
gonna do a lot of them yeah it's not
your first time yeah I always say that
if you got caught stealing if you got
caught lying if you got caught doing bad
[__] you have a history of doing bad
[__] it's not that's just the first time
you got it well tell the D.A here in
California that oh dude I mean yeah this
this new guy Craig Mitchell I'm voting
for him he was a school teacher forever
I sent him I sent it to Rogan I said
Rogan get this guy on your podcast he
was a D.A he was a school teacher for 14
years he was a a prosecutor for 11 years
in LA and then he he's been a judge I
think he's been a supreme court just uh
no he's he's been a whatever federal
jail no he's been a state job okay but
he said the things I've seen in my
courtroom are so outrageous because this
gas gone this his office terrible just a
bunch of [__] who just think it's
fine the guy got 13 times he just wants
to ruin said a guy got stabbed 13 times
and gascon's office said it was assault
not not attempted murder 13 times he
almost died running the page he's going
to bed he's like assault horrible all
right what do you got you it's warm in
here bro it's warm I create a lot of
heat it might be the magic mine
feeling better I feel better but I'm hot
because the AC they decide to cut down
some happy you do better you do very
well in the cold I do well at all but I
would yeah I'd prefer in my studio to be
cold yeah but yeah in the middle you
have no problem with the cold like when
you played football when you were like
oh it's not old no no because I'm not
[__] right but
um but I could not do that no it's not
for you so when you would when you
played in the real cold yeah so I've
always we'd have guys like you who'd
suck but how do you when you're hitting
each other and it's that cold it's got
to be awful how the [__] do you deal
with that [__] you know you just play
ball did you ever play with your like
the guys who play with no sleeves yeah
show everybody I don't wear sleeves man
really no
yeah
psychological thing no it's just I'd
have like a down jacket on under my [__]
yeah you wouldn't be on the field though
right you don't know yeah
all right so this is more like you know
rumor mill stuff but there's there's
something that was going on between Joe
Jonas and Sophie Turner I heard they got
divorcedures of Thrones yeah that's why
I brought it up because you guys are
both huge fans of game Game of Thrones
and now apparently the the thing that
broke this the straw that broke the
camel's back was some sort of footage
either it was like a video footage or
some audio thing on on their ring camera
where Joe Jonas wanted to get a divorce
yeah apparently she likes to party a lot
he likes to stay home
so whatever she said something probably
here heard some [__] yeah and then he
was like that's the last thing yeah and
they probably she was probably out she's
probably like he's so boring I'm trying
to suck and snore which is kind of hot
yeah that's what I call it they turn
hotter yeah I like that our boy Jay
Moore got married to Jeannie Buss that's
right have that too celebration there we
go bam oh there's your boys
congrats Jay Moore one of the funniest
people on the planet he's the best he
posts a great picture yeah uh not that
one who's that guy I don't know oh my
God no but he no I mean there we go
that's so cool though shout out to
Lakers I heard that um
uh he was he was he and jokoy were
hilarious he told me man yeah
so funny he went on before he goes he
walks in he goes oh good to see I'm
gonna go on and what he's you're next
I'm gonna go on all right dude 30
minutes of just improv and crushing yeah
just straight off the Dome such a Savage
and then we get done around midnight
because you want to go get tattoos
oh what it's midnight Joe he goes I know
I get this tattoo artist man I do want
one but I'm not good and he goes yeah
I'm gonna get this full sleeve I'm like
bro you're gonna be up to seven in the
morning he's like you'll go after like
hey he flies private it doesn't matter
yeah yeah different animal when you fly
private you can do whatever you want
he's in movies
all right this is uh pretty impressive
this is a Nebraska women's volleyball
team that filled up the stadium with 90
000 fans enjoy them beating whoever they
beat because my CU Buster and beat the
[__] out of him on Saturday at 10 A.M
that is well I mean this is super
impressive yeah that's volleyball though
right yeah but I mean it's 90 000 people
that's what I'm saying that's incredible
thousand people for volleyball they're
good too yeah the women's team's good
but I mean that's that's that's I think
it's the biggest women's event of all
time right yeah how is it that they're
that interested in volleyball I have no
clue oh I know because Nebraska they
have nothing to do and that team
dominates I mean you're in the nosebleed
seats watching volleyball that's
impressive I hope Nebraska won yeah
oh they won yeah they won and George's
house this is great this is from the new
uh Tyson Fury Netflix doc now have you
been watching is it good I watched the
first two episodes it's really good yeah
he's such a character
all right here we go
Let me refresh come on it's a computer
bro
and go let's give it a sec
one of these days it'll happen
um
oh he's cute playing well
what a cutie pie
Let me refresh our dial-up internet's
not working right now I think the
computer's just too hot
it is hot in here yeah computer's hot
computer and I'm afraid these cameras
might die we should probably get going
then huh see if this works
so he tries
well you get the point you tried cutting
his own hair yeah
I bet he's a [__]
my God that's hilarious
I bet he's a fun dad
this Show's so good I'll start watching
because I love them oh he's cute trying
to be like so cute I won't spoil
anything but there he goes oh my God
he's so cute he's so cute they keep such
a similar lifestyle no matter all these
five studies gaining money it's just
like going away and he's just taking his
wife on cute little date that's what
keeps you grounded man in the insanity
dude I did the opposite so I grew my
hair out for my kids and so like me they
both I've had their hair long and I was
like oh he's like Dad I don't care what
you doing like I'll do it that's why my
hair is long for them
thick hair oh yeah I mean bossy's here
is long daddy gonna be gray in about 10
years but it's not gonna look bad no
I'll be I'll be that Silver Fox yeah
you're gonna be big also I'll still be
getting snorts and socks oh 100 let's be
a snorting suck in this tour is hitting
Covina California the thing's sold out
spoken Washington September 21st through
the 23rd then me and uh snort Fest here
Vegas September 29th
kid with the skank Fest boys at 8pm on
Friday can't wait yeah we'll be doing on
the 29th Dubuque Iowa
Dubuque Iowa never heard of it Dubuque
Iowa I'm there October 13th through the
14th it's Friday Saturday San Jose just
got announced San Jose Improv one night
only Quick Trip Thursday October 19th
that just went on sale two shows San
Jose October 19th uh San Jose Improv
Niagara Falls November 4th through the
5th Chicago just got added in December
December 8th through the 9th and I am
going to be at the Funny Bone in Omaha
ladies and gentlemen September 15 and
16. I am no longer at the King Center in
Melbourne Florida and I'm not going to
be doing the Genesee Theater I don't
believe uh September 24th in Waukegan
we're going to reschedule those uh
because something came up so I have to
reschedule I apologize to everybody
about that
um but uh come see me at the Omaha Funny
Bone September 15 and 16 Friday Saturday
we gotta rock and roll let's go
is that it that's it all right kids love
you go Buffs